vraiment pourquoi votre version serait
la bonne
parce que j'avance à rome nous avons des
preuves et ça c'est une c'est une
première tout le monde est parti dans
des théories là vous avez des documents
vous avez la cassette et surtout j'ai pu
prouver que billy sol était sont
utilisés et une fois que vous prouver
que billy sol est vraiment le un
conseiller johnson vous pouvez le croire
et puis j'ai entendu j'ai entendu cette
cassette enregistrant 71 ou cliff carter
explique que lyndon johnson a donné
l'ordre d'abattre kennedy voilà donc
william reymond et billy soliste
eastleigh s'appelle jfk le dernier
témoin c'est publié chez flammarion
je suis allée des questions les les
archives les archives de la cia ne sont
pas ouvertes toutes les cinquante ans
aux états unis
vous savez les archives il faut pas trop
fantasmer dessus parce que les archives
ont annulé selon la sq on a bien envie
de 10 mètres sont des traces écrites
sont des rapports l'assassinât de
kennedy s'est pas décidée par écrit il
n'y a pas de courrier la poste
correspondance détruit tout ce qu'ils
voulaient détruire tout ce qui pourrait
amener quelqu'un il le balance bien